So let's look at the more general
redundancy-based approach which is
the N-module redundancy.
For N = 2, we have already
seen a brief example of that.
We call this dual-module redundancy and
we have seen that it can
guarantee detection, but
not also correction of one fault.
Or one faulty module for that matter.
Note that we can detect, sometimes,
more than one fault, as long as these
faults are in the same module, or
as long as they're affecting
different results of the modules.
But all we can guarantee really,
is that a single fault will be detected
and we cannot guarantee its correction
because really this technique
doesn't correct anything.
N = 3 gives us what's called
triple-module redundancy,
and it allows us to
correct any one fault, or
even all faults,
produced by a single faulty module.
Again, sometimes we can tolerate
more than one faulty module
if the two faults in the different
modules don't affect the same result.
But all that we can really
guarantee as far as the number
of faults we can correct is that all
faults that occur within the same module
will be corrected, and
that's because the other two modules are
functioning correctly and their correct
outputs are going to output whatever
the faulty one is producing.
We also have examples when N = 5, and
that would be called
five-module redundancy.
A good example for
that is the space shuttle.
It has five computers that are doing
the same thing, and then they vote.
If we get one wrong result in a vote,
we just continue normal
operation of the space shuttle.
If we get two wrong results in a vote,
the mission would be aborted, but
there is still no failure
because the three
correct wrong results are still
out voting the two bad ones.
We are aborting our mission because
if another module fails, and
now we have three wrong results in
our vote, we can no longer correct
that and we can get the bye-bye
space shuttle scenario.
So the idea Is if we got one vote wrong,
we know we can tolerate more than that
without any problems, so
we would just continue normal operation.
These missions are expensive, so
really if there is a single failure we
want to be able to continue normally.
Another one happening after the first
computer has had a problem, is a very
rare occurrence, and we would abort the
mission because now we have some time
to safely land the space shuttle while
we still have three functioning modules.
If it ever gets to another
one failing after that,
we can no longer promise that things
will be correct and at that point,
we are risking the astronauts' lives and
possibly some people on Earth, too.
So that's why the mission gets
aborted before this happens.